sure it's me single no I think that is
partially coming the scientist that I
shall have to trust your own judgment as
well and go for the really long term
goals that no one else has up but
there are many scientists who I admire
but I think will be kind of wrong to
mention one by name because I never
always forget the second one mmm no but
as you say it it is extremely important
to support that we have got from other
scientists and that they have believed
in us and given advice when we needed
advice for example when we started with
our labs just half year after our PhDs
that was a crazy decision but still
people supported us and said we can do
it and if you focus on this and asked if
you collaborate instead of splitting and
trying to build two labs and so on and
but since since the context is Nobel
prizes you can always mention a few
names at least so Eric on dell is his
work we got exposed to very early our
sort of already in the 1980s was work
that we read about and thought was super
exciting and then we met him and he sort
of followed us all the way another one
is tossed in diesel was also relation to
Sweden so his work in the 60s especially
it was extreme you've been obese and it
was just like the Bible and the same
would come dancing defined our field so
those two are at least persons who have
meant a lot both for our field and for
us yeah and also for my PhD and I
studied structural changes after
different experiences like living in an
enriched environment and then and it was
so fantastic for me to read about their
place yeah
eric kandel because he had shown the
same thing in depressive and this tiny
slunk is a learning sea slug is learning
and then I could believe also in my own
data because i had read his work so in a
lot of different locations these people
have been important and also when we
were master students